all right let's go to Kody in Houston
hey Kody how are you hey David still
good to finally be able to talk to you
the line I've been a fan of yours for a
long time I just want to kind of
introduce myself a little bit kind of
quickly I'm a 22 year old college
student I've managed to save over
$20,000 and a cold hard cash I have any
debts that paid for all my school out of
my own pocket
my question was today is outside one day
well basically my goal is to one day I
want to buy a certain luxury car that
you know the brand-new price is around
200,000 or so let's go in which car in
this which currently a Bentley a very
nice nice car it's like financial
condition do I need to be near services
10 years from now 10 years so now
whenever to whatever point that is what
kind of condition I need to be in what
kind of savings I need to have or yeah
basically what kind of commission I need
to be in to be able to reasonably afford
something that's very expensive to get
off the lot and expensive to maintain I
don't like well what is that condition
now well we tell people not to buy
vehicles that are more than half their
annual income because vehicles go down
in value we tell people not to buy a new
car at least unless you have at least a
million dollar net worth but you
wouldn't buy a $200,000 car with only a
million dollar net worth cars are
awesome I've got some really nice cars
myself but you want a net worth the
point that the car is a small percentage
of your net worth and 20 percent of your
net worth tied up in a car will be
stupid you know it's going it's going
the wrong way
Bentley's a fine automobile but it's
going down in value so you're going to
need two to four million dollar net
worth you ought to be making several
hundred thousand a year before you do
that hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and say you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up
that your broke friends think you've
lost your mind